foreign
carr antonio
bravka switzerland
excellence honorable members but most
and foremost
my dear and fellow europeans
on this very special day of europe
i could not think of any more fitting
way to start than by using these words
of ozula hirschmann for those who do not
know her story
ozora hirschmann was an architect and
builder
of today's free and united europe
she resisted the rise of nazism in
berlin
in the early nineteen thirties
she shaped the future of europe on the
island of entertainer
in the nineteen forties
she pioneered women's rights all across
europe
the courage of her actions and of her
convictions
helped to make europe what it is today
and i start with this picture
because for europe
the memory of our past
has always framed our future
and that is all the more important at a
time when the unthinkable has returned
to our continent
russia's flagrant attempts to redraw
maps
and to rewrite
even the most tragic parts of our
history
have reminded us of the dangers
of losing our grip on both
our past
and our future
on living in a perpetual present and
thinking that things can never be
different
that there cannot be better ways of
doing things and even worse
that things will always stay the same if
only we do not change
that's so wrong
standing still is falling back
but this conference
this conference has shown us
that europeans are determined not to
make this mistake
you you have told us
that you want to build a better future
by living up to the most enduring
promises of the past
promises
of peace
and
prosperity fairness
and progress
of a europe that is social and
sustainable
that is caring and daring just like
ozola hirschmann and all those who went
before us
ladies and gentlemen
this conference has spoken clearly
and i'm delighted to see so many of you
here today
through your 49 proposals and more than
300 measures
you have weaved and crafted a vision of
a europe
that delivers on metal and what matters
most that helps to make everyday life
better
that is not confined to one place
but it is it is at your side when you
need it
on every day priorities such as the air
we breathe
or the food we eat
the education that we give to our
children
and the houses that we bring them up in
it is a vision of a europe that pools
its strengths and capacities and
diversity
to tackle the biggest challenges
from climate change
or nature loss
to pandemics
or security in our region
a europe
that has a stronger capacity to activate
and uphold its values and the rule of
law
a europe that is able to provide for
itself
in vital areas
from energy
to
food
from materials
to medicines
from digital chips
to green technologies
europe that delivers unique social
protections and benefits all the way
through these major transitions
ladies and gentlemen
i want to address every single one of
you
who took part in this conference
your message has been well received
and now
it's time to deliver
that is what i promised when i stood for
election in this very house two and a
half years ago
and together we have proven
that we can do just that
with the powers that already exist
even amidst the pandemic or war
whether procuring billions of vaccines
for citizens across europe and our
neighborhood
or kick starting the economy after the
pandemic through next generation eu
whether setting an ambitious and legally
binding path to climate neutrality
or setting rules of the game in the
digital world
or supporting small businesses to retain
their staff during the pandemic
none of this
none
would have been explicitly foreseen in
the treaties
but it was possible
and we did it together
because europeans expected their union
to step up
so
next month already
we will set out what is needed to bring
your proposals to life and respond the
best we can
in some areas
your proposals give us a push to speed
up work already ongoing
for example on the european green deal
or on making society fairer
so that means accelerating negotiations
on the fit for 55 package
so that we can boost renewable energies
that we can save energy
and finally wean ourselves out of fossil
fuels it has to be
and it means ensuring that our proposal
on minimum wages
becomes law
so that work pays for all
in other areas we have already started
the work
you have asked for
the health working group for example
proposed creating a european health data
space
which would facilitate the exchange of
health data across borders
well
my commission delivered last week with a
proposal
and in the next weeks and months we will
bring out proposals
you have been asking for
for example restoring our nature
or cutting down waste from package
or banning products
made by forced labor
from entering our european market
on all of these upcoming ideas
we will look closely at your proposals
so that we can best cater for what you
have been asking for
the point is
there is already a lot we can do without
delay
and that also goes for those
recommendations which we will which will
need us to take new actions
so to make sure
that we follow up swiftly
i will announce the first new proposals
responding to your reports
in my state of the union address in
september already
[Applause]
but my fellow europeans even beyond this
there is a need to go further
for example i have always argued
that unanimity voting in some key areas
simply no longer makes sense if we want
to be able to move faster
[Applause]
or that europe should play
a greater role for example in health
or defense
after the experience of the last two
years
and we need to improve the way our
democracy works on a permanent basis
i want to be clear
that i will always be on the side of
those
who want to reform the european union to
make it work better
the point is
you have told us
where you want this europe to go
and it's now up to us
to take the most
direct way there
either
by using the full limits
of what we can do within the treaties or
yes by changing the treaties if need be
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen dear fellow
europeans
democracy has not gone out of fashion
but it must update itself in order to
keep improving people's lives
those are the words of david sasoli
a great european who stood here
a year ago together with you dear
antonio costa
to launch this conference
we all miss him dearly
and i have a very special place for him
in my heart today
and i feel pride
that citizens from every corner of
europe have brought life to his vision
of a vibrant and modern modern european
democracy
we saw it in the national citizens panel
such as those held right across france
and we saw it in the european citizens
panels from dublin to natalie natalin
from florence to maastricht
it connected men and women
who have never engaged with europe
before
different stories different languages
different identities but one shared
future
to build on
you have proven
that this form of democracy works
and i believe
we should give it more room it should
become part of the way we make policy
and this is why i will propose that in
future
we give citizen panels the time and the
resources
to make recommendation before we present
key legislative proposals
because democracy
because i'm convinced that democracy
does not end with elections conferences
or conventions
it needs to be worked on nurtured and
improved every day
we saw it in the grassroots events held
right across europe
whether debate debating biodiversity in
varna gender-based violence in lisbon or
democracy and subsidiarity in budapest
and we saw it
indeed in the image of linda
the young mother
we saw earlier this day speaking about
the future
in this very hemi cycle with holding her
baby born halfway through the conference
ladies and gentlemen
this is the image
i want us to celebrate on the 9th of may
an image far more powerful
than any military deep parade and debate
going up and down the streets of moscow
as we speak
[Applause]
and i want
and i want this image to remind us to
never ever take for granted what europe
is
and what it means
europe is a dream
a dream that always was
a dream born from tragedy
but today
that dream shines brightest not only
here in this historic place it shines
brightest in the hearts and minds of the
people of kief and kharkiv of odessa and
mario paul
it shines brightest in the courage of
those families and young people bunkered
down in subways and basements
it shines brightest of those mourning
the senseless mindless atrocities of
bucha and in european and in every
ukrainian village and town struck by war
and it shines brightest
in the eyes of all those young
ukrainians who have found refuge in
europe a home away from home
those people my fellow europeans young
and old
are willing to fight and to die
for their future and for that dream of
fuel
that dream that always was
that dream that must always be
so i want to finish
with a message this morning i had a
video conference with president
zielinski
and he wanted to virtually hand me over
his answers to the questionnaire
of the commission
for the accession process he has applied
to
it is more than 5 000 pages he hand it
over to me
and therefore i want to give a very
special message to our ukrainian friends
and families
the future of europe
is also your future
the future of our democracy
is also the future of your democracy
77 years ago
war in europe was replaced with
something different
something new
first a community
today a union
it was the day when the future began
it is a future that we have been writing
together ever since
as architects and builders of europe
and the next page dear ukrainian friends
is now being written by you by us by all
of us together slava ukrainia long live
europe
[Applause]
you